okay hi everyone let's get started so
Chris is traveling this week so he's not
here but I'm very excited to say that
today we've got Margaret Mitchell who is
a senior research scientist at Google AI
and she's gonna tell us about the latest
work defining and understanding and
improving the situation with bias in
artificial intelligence Margaret has a
background working in NLP and deep
learning so I'm really interested to
hear what she has to say today take it
away
great thank you and can you guys hear me
okay I'm not sure if this mic is exactly
picking up my bus everything's cool okay
cool um so this work is the product of a
ton of different people and
collaborators that I've tried to put up
here some students at Stanford also
Johns Hopkins Google Facebook and
Microsoft are all represented cool so um
for those of you who haven't seen this
set of slides before what do you see
here just shout it up bananas okay what
else
stickers what else bananas with stickers
on them you can start doing like
embedded clauses you know bunches of
bananas with stickers on them on shelves
in the store to get kind of crazy but we
don't tend to say yellow bananas right
so give them something like this we
might say green bananas or we might say
unripe bananas given an image like this
we might say ripe bananas or bananas
with spots on them if you're me you
might say bananas that are good for
banana bread and but given an image like
this or something like this in the real
world we tend not to mention the
yellowness and the reason for this is
because yellow is prototypical for
bananas so the idea of prototypes stems
from prototype theory which goes back to
the early
coming out of the work of Eleanor Rosch
and colleagues and it's this idea that
there are some stored central
prototypical notions of objects that we
access as we're operating throughout the
world there's some disagreement about
whether these prototypes are actual
exemplars of objects or something like a
distribution over what's likely but
there is general agreement that we do
have some sort of sense of what's
typical and what's a typical of the
things in the world and we tend to
notice and talk about the things that
are atypical so this is a riddle that I
heard in middle school that worked a
little bit more at that time some of you
might have heard it before a man and his
son are in a terrible accident and are
rushed to the hospital in critical care
the doctor looks at the boy and exclaims
I can't operate on this boy he's my son
how could this be - Deb's or more he has
them on her doctor right otherwise known
as a female doctor which might be
contract is contrasted with doctor in a
study they did when they first sort of
put forward this riddle at Boston
University they found that the majority
of test subjects overlooked the
possibility that the doctor could be a
she and that included men women and
self-described feminists so the point is
that these kinds of ways of talking
about things and assumptions that we
make aren't necessarily something that
speaks to negative intent but something
that speaks to how we actually store
representations in our minds and how we
access those representations as we
interact in the world so this this
affects what we can learn when we're
learning from text so this is work from
2013 where they took a look at what was
sort of most likely what would you learn
if you were just learning from raw text
what were some things that were common
in the world um and they found that in
this set up something like murdering was
ten times
likely than blinking and the reason for
this is because people tend not to
mention these typical things that go
without saying we don't tend to mention
things like blinking and breathing but
we do mention atypical events like
murder and that affects the kind of
things a machine can learn from text
that we put out in the world because
it's been subject to all of these
filtering processes that we have as
humans before we communicate this issue
in particular is known as human
reporting bias which is that the
frequency with which people write about
actions outcomes or properties is not a
reflection of real-world frequencies or
the degree to which a property is
characteristic of a class of individuals
but says a lot more about how we're
actually processing the world and what
we think is remarkable so this affects
everything a system can learn in a
typical machine learning paradigm one of
the first steps is to collect and
potentially annotate training data from
there a model can be trained from there
media can be filtered ranked ranked
aggregated generated in some way and
from there people see the output and we
like to think of this as a relatively
straightforward pipeline but at the very
start even before we're collecting with
the data actually within the data itself
are a host of different kinds of human
biases so things like stereotyping
things like prejudice things like a
racism and that's embedded within the
data before we collect it then as we
collect and annotate data further biases
become introduced so things like
sampling errors confirmation bias
in-group bias and out-group bias and
I'll talk about these a little bit oh
and I should mention feel free to ask
questions as I go totally fine to just
kind of interact throughout so here are
some of the biases that I think are
relatively important for work in AI
machine learning there's hundreds you
can go into but some of the ones that
I've sort of become the most aware of
working in this space are this set and
I'll go through each of these a bit so I
talked about reporting bias earlier
which is which affects what we can learn
from
another example of a kind of bias that
really affects what we can learn from
text is selection bias so a lot of times
that we a lot of times when we get data
annotated we do something like Amazon's
Mechanical Turk and the distribution of
workers across the world is not an even
sort of uniform distribution it's
actually concentrated in India the US
and then some in Europe so this leaves
out South America this leaves out Africa
this leaves out a lot of China and that
affects the kind of things that we'll be
able to learn about the world when we
have things annotated another kind of
bias is out-group homogeneity bias which
is the tendency to see out group members
as more alike than in-group members and
this is going to affect what people are
able to describe and talk about when
they're annotating things such as
emotion so so for example we have these
two like adorable puppies on the left
here and they're looking at these four
cats and these are all different black
cats very different in different ways
but the two puppies look at the cats and
they see four cats basically the same
and it's kind of trivial to understand
how that also extends to human cognition
and how we also process people it's this
it's the sense we have that the the
cohort that we're in the people that we
interact with those are the kinds of
people that are nuanced and everybody
else is somehow less nuanced has less
detail to them it's a trick our minds
play on us in order to help us process
the world but it affects how we talk
about it and it affects further how we
annotate it this leads to stuff like
bias data representations so it's
possible that you have an appropriate
amount of data for every possible human
group you can think of in your data but
it might be the case that some groups
are represented less positively than
others and if we have time I'll go into
a long a longer example of that it also
leads to things like biased labels so
this is a issue that came up when we
were getting some annotations for
inclusive images competition asking
people to annotate things like bride and
wedding and groom and we found that
given three different kinds of bride
wedding
room images ones that were more Western
European American got the appropriate
labels and ones that weren't just got
sort of more generic person kinds of
labels not able to actually tease out
what's actually happening in these
images companies issue our biases in
interpretation when the model outputs
its decisions so one one issue is
confirmation bias which is the tendency
to search for interpret favor recall
information in a way that confirms
pre-existing beliefs and so a lot of
times when we build and to end systems
and try and test our hypotheses were
kind of just testing it towards things
that we want to be true and analyzing
the results in a way that will help
confirm what we want to be true over
generalization which is coming to a
conclusion based on information that's
too general or not specific enough this
is an issue that happens a lot of times
in the analysis of deep learning model
results where it's assumed that there's
there's some kind of general conclusion
that can be taken away when really it's
actually just an effect of really skewed
data this is also closely related to
overfitting which is kind of the machine
learning version of over generalization
which is where you're still making
predictions and outcomes but it's based
on a small set of possible features so
it's not actually capturing the space of
the correct features for the outcome the
desired output prediction correctly
there's also correlation fallacy which
is confusing correlation with causation
and this happens a lot again in talking
about what machine learning models are
learning and deep learning models are
learning in particular where just
because things happen together doesn't
mean that one is causing the other but
models don't tell you anything deep
learning models directly don't tell you
anything about the causal relations and
so it's easy to think that some output
that is predicted based on a correlation
is actually something that's causal and
I'll talk about some examples of this
too
a further issue is automation bias and
this really affects the machine learning
models we put out there in the world
get used by people in systems like
justice systems so that's the tendency
to favor the suggestions of automatic
predictions of models that output
predictions over the over the different
kinds of suggestions of another human
and this happens even in the face of
contradictory evidence so if a system is
telling you you know this this is the
score or this is the risk of this
individual then we're more likely to
think it's true because it came out of a
mathematical system and we automatically
sort of see this as something more
objective something more mathematical
that something's going to be more true
than human some somehow and that's
automation bias so rather than this kind
of clean straightforward pipeline that
we have in machine learning and we have
human bias coming in at the very start
in the data and then human bias coming
in in data collection annotation and
then further getting propagated through
the system as we train on that data as
we start putting outputs based on that
data as people act on that data and this
creates a feedback loop where the kinds
of things that we output for people to
act on are then are then then serves as
further training data for input for new
system so you end up amplifying even
further these different kinds of
implicit biases this is known as a bias
Network effect or bias Laundering I like
to call it and so the message is that
human data perpetuates human biases and
then as as machine learning or deep
learning learns from human data the
result is a bias network effect so I
want to steer clear the idea that if I
say bias or if someone says bias that
equals bad it's a little bit more
nuanced than that so there are all kinds
of things that people mean when they're
talking about bias and even the same
bias can be good in some situations and
bad in some situations so bias in
statistics on ml we could we talked
about the bias of an estimator which is
the difference between the predictions
and the and the truth for ground truth
we talked about the bias term in linear
rushon we also have cognitive biases and
I talked about that in the beginning and
not all of those are negative or or have
to be or have to be seen as negative so
optimism is another kind of bias that we
can have that affects our worldview and
the way we sort of process things and
even things like recency bias and
confirmation bias are just ways that our
minds can like handle the combinatorial
explosion of all the different things
that can be true in the world and put it
down to something tractable that we can
sort of operate with in the real world
and so algorithmic bias is what a lot of
people mean and headlines and whatnot
when they're talking about bias which is
more about unjust unfair or prejudicial
treatment of people that's an output of
an automated decision system and the
focus here is really on unjust unfair or
prejudicial treatment of people so a lot
of the work in this space right now is
focusing on trying to understand what
does it mean to be unjust from an
algorithm what does it mean to be unfair
from an algorithm and how can we handle
this how can we sort of mitigate these
issues in order to be able to keep
developing technology that's useful for
people without worsening social divides
and I thought the Guardian put it really
well a few years ago they said although
neural networks might be said to write
their own programs they do so towards
goals set by humans using data collected
for human purposes if the data is skewed
even by accident the computers will
amplify injustice and it really keyed in
on this amplify and justice idea and
let's talk about what that can mean so
one of the avenues of deep learning
research that's taken off in the past
few years is predicting criminal
behavior so how many of you are familiar
with predictive policing okay like half
of the class okay
so in predictive policing algorithms are
predict areas to deploy officers where
crime is considered to be likely to
occur but the data that the the models
are trained off of is based on where
police off
SURS have already gone and made arrests
so the systems are simply learning the
patterns of bias that humans have in
where they go and where they are trying
to decide to defer to find crime and
then reflecting them back so because the
system hones in on some of the top spots
where people have been arrested notice
that's not the same of nuts the same
thing as where crimes have been
committed right it's where arrests have
been made it means that the other areas
that might be explored for crime don't
get explored at all that worsens the
situation some neighborhoods get really
acutely focused attention on them and
that heightens the chances of serious
repercussions for even minor infractions
that means arrests and that means a
feedback loop of data that you will get
an arrest in this place if you go there
another sort of related issue in this
space is predictive sentencing so there
was a really nice article that came out
from Pro Publica a few years ago
discussing this but when most defendants
are booked in jail they respond to a
questionnaire called compass and their
answers are fed into this software
system that generates scores that
correspond to the risk of recidivism
that's the risk of making a crime again
and the questions are used to gather
data on the defendants socioeconomic
status family background neighborhood
crime employment status and other
factors in order to reach some
predictive prediction of an individual's
crime or criminal risk but once ends up
happening is that it ends up focusing on
the key bias issues that humans have and
propagating it back with something that
looks like an objective score so you're
a lot more likely to be convicted of a
crime if you're black than if you're
white even if you've made the exact same
crime and the system will pick up on
this and will reflect this back to say
that people who are black are more
likely to have received like recidivism
more likely to convict him to make a
crime again so this is an example of
automation bias preferring the output of
a system
in the face of overgeneralization
feedback loops and correlation fallacy
confusing things that are occurring
together as being somehow causal there's
another sort of area of research and
startups looking at predicting
criminality in particular some things
like face images so there's a company
out there called face ception they're
based in Israel and they claim to be
able to use individual images with
computer vision and machine learning
technology for profiling people and
revealing their personality based only
on their facial image recognizing things
like high IQ white-collar offender had a
file and terrorists and their main
clients are homeland security lots of
other lots of other countries dealing
with sort of public safety issues
they've not published any details about
their methods their sources of training
data or their quantitative results we
know that in light of automation bias
people will tend to think it just works
even when it doesn't work well but there
was a paper that came out within a
similar line in predicting criminal
criminality or purporting to predict
criminality from individual face images
and that one had some results and some
more details about the data that we
could kind of dig into to understand
where are these kinds of claims coming
from so this was an article that was
posted on archive near the end of 2016
and they said they were using less than
2000 closely cropped images of faces
including wanted suspect ID pictures
from specific regions and they claimed
that even based on this very small
training data set that they were able to
predict whether or not someone was
likely to be a criminal greater than 90
percent accuracy
um and they got so lost in this this
idea that it's sort of funny to read to
just take a step back and realize what's
actually happening so for example one of
their really great exciting claims was
that the angle theta from nose tip 2 to
mouth corners is on average nineteen
point six percent smaller for criminals
for non-criminals this is otherwise
known as smiling and my you know exactly
the kind of images people would use when
trying to put out wanted criminal
pictures probably not really happy
pictures but you get so lost in the
confirmation bias you get so lost in the
correlation and the feedback loops that
you end up overlooking these really
obvious kinds of things so that's an
example of selection bias experimenters
bias confirmation bias correlation
fallacy and feedback loops all coming
together to create a deep learning
system that people think is scary and
can do things that it can't actually do
one of the issues with this was that the
media loved it like it's was all over
the news and there's been similar kinds
of things happening again and again
media wants to sell this story and so
it's part of our job as researchers that
people who work on this stuff to be very
clear about what the technology is
actually doing and make a distinction
between what you might think it's doing
and what it's actually doing um so
another issue that has come up recently
is claiming to be able to predict
internal qualities but specifically ones
that are subject to discrimination and
loss of opportunity so in particular
there was this work that came out that
claimed to be able to predict whether or
not someone was homosexual just based on
single face images now it's important to
know that the images that they used in
the study included images that were from
dating websites where people
self-identified as straight or gay and
identified as whether they were looking
for a partner who is straight or gay and
these became the sources of the training
data and still from this Oh before I go
on can you guys just understand just
from that what the issue might have been
imposed
there was actually anything about
rainbows but that's really unfortunate
right yes this has more to do with the
presentation of the self the
presentation of the social self when
you're trying to for example attract a
partner on a website and less to do with
how you look day-to-day and yet they
kind of went to these large conclusions
that aren't supported at all by the data
or by their study but things like
consistent with a prenatal formula of
sexual orientation gay men and women
tended to have gender atypical facial
morphology now none of the authors
actually were prenatal hormone Theory
specialists you know they had doctor in
their name so maybe that's the thing
this was a Stanford professor and like
I've presented this a few times at
Stanford and gotten into some like
pretty harsh fights about this so I'm
ready if anyone wants to take me on but
but me and my some of my colleagues
decided we we play around with this a
bit what we found was that a simple
decision tree so I'm kind of assuming
you guys know what a decision tree is
okay cool so based on wearing makeup or
wearing glasses God is pretty close to
the accuracy reported in the paper
that says nothing about internal
hormones that says nothing about any of
that and says a lot about the physical
presentation the things that are on the
surface it says a lot more about how
people are presenting themselves and
what is happening internally so the key
thing that's recently kind of been
overlooked is that deep learning is
somehow it's sort of considered that
it's somehow magically going beyond
surface level but the point is that it's
working on the surface level and working
well and in the face of confirmation
bias and other kinds of bias factors
it's easy to assume that something else
is happening that's not without critical
examination for example simple baselines
simple sanity checks and these kinds of
things can just be ignored and and not
noticed at all so that's example of
selection bias and experimenters bias
and correlation fallacy
okay so now I'm going to talk to talk
about measuring algorithmic bias so I
just said a lot about different kinds of
biases that come in in the data in the
collection in the interpretation of the
results let's talk about actually
quantitatively measuring different kinds
of biases so one of the key things
that's emerged in a few different works
and really ties nicely to a lot of
fairness work is this idea of
disaggregated evaluation so in
disaggregated evaluation you evaluate
across different subgroups as opposed to
looking at one single score for your
overall testing data set so okay you
guys are probably familiar with the
training testing data split you kind of
train on there on your given training
data you test on your given testing data
and you point you report like precision
recall F score or things like that but
what that masks is how well the system
is actually working across different
kinds of individuals and across
different different subgroups and so one
just straightforward way to handle this
is to actually evaluate with respect to
those different subgroups so creating
for each sort of subgroup prediction
pair so for an example you might look at
women face detection men face detection
and look at how the the error rates are
different or similar um another
important part of this is to look at
things intersectionally combining things
like gender and race at the same time
and seeing how those how the error rates
on those sorts of things change and how
they're different across different
intersections and this is inspired by
kimberlé crenshaw
because she she pioneered intersectional
research in critical race theory and she
discussed the story of emma de Graaff
infeed who was a woman at General Motors
and she claimed that the company is
hiring practices discriminated against
black women but in their Court opinion
the judges ruled that General Motors
hired many women for secretarial
positions and many black people her
factory roles and thus they could not
have discriminated against black women
what they failed to do was look at the
intersection of the two and understand
that the experience there might be
fundamentally different than any of the
experiences of either of these sort of
subgroups in isolation and the same
becomes true when you start looking at
errors that are regularly made in deep
learning systems so we've been able to
uncover a lot of different kinds of
unintended errors by looking not only at
the disaggregated evaluation but also at
intersectional disaggregated evaluation
so I'm going to walk through a bit how
this works this is probably going to be
review for most of you but I think it's
really important to understand this
because it also ties to how we measure
fairness and when we say like
algorithmic fairness what we're talking
about so um the confusion matrix is a
way you guys okay are you guys familiar
with the Confucian matrix I just want to
know where okay awesome cool so familiar
to take from you is a matrix right so
you have model predictions and
references and you can kind of look at
these as negative and positive binary
classification kind of approach here
where if the ground truth says something
is true and the model predicts it's true
it's a true positive if the ground truth
says it's it's it's false and the model
predicts it's false it's true negative
and the air is the kind of different
issues that arise are false negatives
and false positives so in false
positives the the ground truth says
something is negative but the model
predicts that it's positive and then in
false negatives vice versa
from these you know basic kind of this
basic breakdown of errors you can get a
few different metrics these metrics
actually trivially map to a lot of
different fairness criteria so for
example if we're looking at something
like female versus male patient results
and figuring out things like precision
and recall which is relatively common in
NLP if you have equal recall across your
subgroups
that's the same as the fairness criteria
of equality of opportunity I could work
through the math but I mean this is
basically just just the main point that
that
it says that given that something is
true in the ground truth the model
should predict that it's true at equal
rates across different subgroups so this
ends up being equivalent to having the
same recall across different subgroups
similarly having the same precision
across different subgroups is equivalent
to a fairness criterion called
predictive parity and so as fairness has
been defined again and again it was
originally some of these definitions
came in 1966 following the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 they were reinvented a few
times and most recently reinvented in
2016 but they all sort of boiled down to
this disaggregated comparison across
subgroups and the math the metrics end
up being roughly equivalent to what we
get from the confusion matrix
specifically in classification systems
so which kind of fairness metric do you
use what are the different criteria you
want to use to look at the differences
across different subgroups that really
it comes down to the trade-offs between
false positives and false negatives so
this is the same problem that you're
dealing with when you're just figuring
out how to evaluate generally there's no
one fairness criterion that is the
fairness criterion to rule them all
deciding which one is better than the
other is the same as kind of trying to
decide which is better precision or
recall right it depends on what the
problem is and what you're interested in
measuring so a case where false
positives might be better than false
negatives and so you want to prioritize
something like a false positive right
across subgroups is privacy in images so
here are false positive is something
that doesn't need to be blurred gets
blurred that's just kind of a bummer but
a false negative would be something that
needs to be blurred as not learned and
that can be identity theft it's a much
more serious issue and so it's important
to prioritize the evaluation metrics
that stress the false negative rates an
example where false negatives might be
better than false positives as in spam
filtering so a false negative could be
an email that's spam
not caught so you see it in your inbox
that's usually just annoying it's not a
big deal and but if false positive here
would be email flagged as spam and then
removed from your inbox which you know
if it's from a friend or a loved one it
can be it can be a loss may be a job
offer or something like that
right so I just kind of covered how a I
can unintentionally timejust outcomes
and some of the things to do or some of
the things to be aware of here
are the lack of insight into sources of
bias in the data in the model
lack of insight into the feedback loops
from the original data that's collected
as an example of what humans do to the
data that's then repurposed reused acted
on and then further fed in a lack of
careful disaggregated evaluation looking
at the disparities the differences
between different subgroups in order to
understand this bias this difference
across the subgroups and then human
biases in interpreting and accepting and
talking about the results which then
kind of further the media cycles and the
hype around AI right now but it's up to
us to influence how AI evolves so I like
to think of this in terms of short term
middle term and long term objectives so
short term today we might be working on
some specific modal where we're trying
to find some local optimum we have a
task we have data something like that
and that sort of short term objectives
we might have a slightly longer term
objective of getting a paper published
or if you're an industry like adding a
product launched whatever it might be
from there we might see our next
endpoint as getting an award or you know
maybe become sort of famous for
something for a few minutes something
like that and that's cool and but
there's a longer-term objective that we
can work towards as well at the same
time and that's something like a
positive outcome for humans in their
environment so instead of just kind of
focusing on these local decisions these
local optimum and these sort of local
paper by paper based approaches to
solving problems you can also kind of
think about what's the long-term
objective where does this
me as they trace out an evolutionary
path for artificial intelligence down
the line in 10 years 15 years 20 years
and one of the ways you can address this
is by thinking you know how can the work
I'm interested in now be best focused to
help others and that involves talking to
experts and kind of going outside your
bubble speaking across interdisciplinary
fields like cognitive science which I've
just talked a bit about so let's talk
about some things we can do so first off
is data so a lot of the issues of bias
and fairness in machine learning models
really come down to the data
unfortunately in machine learning and
deep learning working on data is really
not seen as sexy there's a few data sets
that people use they're out there that's
what people use and there's not a lot of
analysis done on it on how well these
datasets capture different truths about
the world how problematic they might be
but it's a pretty wide area that needs a
lot of future like lead needs a lot of
future additional work so we're gonna
understand the data skews and the
correlations if you understand your data
skews and the correlations that might be
problematic in your data then you can
start working on either models that
address those or data augmentation
approaches in order to sort of make the
data set a little bit better or a little
bit more representative of how you want
the world to be it's also important to
abandon the single training set testing
set from similar distribution approach
to advancing deep learning so when we do
projects in deep learning you know we
tend to have the training set and the
testing set and then that's what we sort
of benchmark on and prioritize but the
point is as you move around different
testing sets you're going to get vastly
different results and so by keeping in
this just sort of one training testing
date training testing data set paradigm
you're really likely to not notice
issues that might otherwise be there and
one way to really focus in on them is
having a hard set of test cases
you really want to make sure the model
does well on so these are things that
are particularly problematic things that
would be really harmful to individuals
if they were to experience the output
and you kind of collect those in a small
test set and then it's really easy to
evaluate on that test set as you
benchmark improvements on your model as
you add different kinds of things to
your model in order to see not just how
your model is doing overall in terms of
your testing data set but how well
you're doing in terms of these examples
you really want it to do well on that
you know that it's going to be a problem
if it doesn't do well on and any sort of
degradation in that you might want to
prioritize to fix above degradation
degradation and overall accuracy and
it's also important to talk to experts
about the additional signals that you
can incorporate so we've put out a tool
to help with this understanding data
SKUs called facets it's just available
there and it's a really handy kind of
visualizer for slicing understanding you
know what some of the differences are
between different subgroups and
different representations and you can
sort of dig in and explore a bit more so
this is just to sort of help people come
to terms with the data that they're
actually using and and where there might
be unwanted associations or or missing
missing kind of features another
approach that's been put forward
recently specifically on the data side
is this data data sheets for data sets
approach so this is this idea that when
you release a data set it's not enough
to just release the data set with like
some pretty graphs and like talking
about basic distributional information
you need to talk about who the
annotators were where they were what the
inner entertainer agreement was what
their background information was
motivation for the data set all these
other kinds of details so now you
actually know that this isn't just a
data set this is a data set that has
these specific biases there's no such
thing as a data set that isn't biased in
some way a data set by virtue of the
fact that it's collected from the world
as a subset is a is a biased set of the
world in some way the point is to make
it clear
what it is how it is biased what are the
what are the various biases that's that
important to know about in the data set
so that's one of these ideas between
behind data sheets for data sets
releasing these data sets publicly all
right now let's switch a little bit to
machine learning so there are a couple
techniques that I like to use I'll talk
about two one is bias mitigation which
is removing the signal for a problematic
output so removing stereotyping sexism
racism trying to remove these kind of
effects from the model this is also
sometimes called D biasing or unbiased
thats a little bit of a misnomer because
you're you're generally just kind of
moving around bias based on a specific
set of words for example so to say it's
unbiased is it's not true
but you are kind of mitigating bias with
respect to some certain kinds of
information that you provide it with and
there's inclusion which is then adding
signal for desired variables so that's
kind of the opposite side of bias
mitigation so increasing model
performance with attention to subgroups
or data slices with the worst
performance so in order to address
inclusion kind of adding signal for
underrepresented subgroups one technique
that's worked relatively well is
multitask learning so I've heard that
you guys have studied multitask learning
which is great so I'll tell you a bit
about a case study here and so this is
work I did in collaboration with a UPenn
world well-being project working
directly with clinicians and the goal
was to create a system that could alert
clinicians if there was a suicide
attempt that was imminent and they
wanted to understand the feasibility of
these kinds of diagnosis when there were
very few training training instances
available so that's similar to kind of
the minority problem in datasets and in
this work we had two kinds of data one
was the internal data which was the
electronic health records with that was
either provided by the patient or from
the family
it included mental health diagnosis
suicide attempts or completions
if that were the case along with the the
users the person's social media data
that was the internal data that we did
not publish on but that we were able to
work with clinicians on in order to
understand if our methods were actually
working the external data the proxy data
the stuff that we could kind of publish
on and talk about was based on Twitter
and this was using regular expressions
in order to extract phrases and Twitter
feeds that had something that was kind
of like diagnosis so something like I've
been diagnosed with X or I've tried to
commit suicide and that became kind of
the the proxy data set and the
corresponding social media feeds for for
those individuals for the actual
diagnosis and the state of the art in
clinical medicine kind of until this
work there's been more recently but is
sort of this single task logistic
regression logistic regression setup
where you have some input features and
then you're making some output
predictions like true or false and you
can add some layers and start making it
deep learning which is much fancier you
can have a bunch of tasks in order to do
a bunch of logistic regression tasks for
a clinical environment or you can use
multi task learning which is taking a
basic deep learning model and adding a
bunch of heads to it predicted jointly
at the same time and here we had a bunch
of diagnosis data so we predicted things
like depression anxiety post-traumatic
stress disorder we also added in gender
because this is something that the
clinicians told us actually had some
correlation with some of these
conditions and that they actually used
it in making decisions themselves for
whether or not someone was likely to
attempt suicide or not and this also
used this idea of comorbidity so
multitask learning is actually kind of
perfect for comorbidity in clinical
domains so comorbidity is and when you
have one condition you're a lot more
likely to have another so people who
have post-traumatic stress disorder are
much more likely to have depression and
anxiety and depression and anxiety tend
to be comorbid so
people who have won often had the other
so this points to the fact this points
to the idea that perhaps there's some
underlying representation that is
similar across them that can be
leveraged in a deep learning model with
individual heads further specifying each
of the different kinds of conditions and
so what we found was that as we moved
from logistic regression to the single
task deep learning to the multi task
deep learning we were able to get
significantly better results and this
was true both in the suicide risk case
where we had a lot of data as well as
the post traumatic stress disorder case
where we had very little data the
behavior here was a little bit different
so going from logistic regression to
single task deep learning when we had a
lot of data as we did with the suicide
risk had the single task deep learning
model working better than the logistic
regression model but when we had very
few instances this is where the deep
learning models really struggled a lot
more and so the logistic regression
models were actually much better but
once we started adding heads for the
comorbid different kinds of conditions
the different kinds of tasks and that
related to you know whether or not the
person might be committing suicide and
we were able to bump the accuracy way
back up again and you know it's roughly
120 at-risk individuals that we were
able to collect in the suicide case that
we wouldn't have otherwise been able to
to notice as being at risk one of the
approaches we took in this was to
contextualize and consider the ethical
dimensions of releasing this kind of
technology so it's really common in NLP
papers to give examples but this was an
area where we decided that giving
examples of like depressed language
could be used to discriminate against
people like add you know job interviews
or something like that you know the sort
of armchair psychology approach so we
decided that while it was important to
talk about the technique and the utility
of multitask learning in a clinical
domain and for bringing an inclusion of
underrepresented subgroups it had to be
balanced with the fact that there was a
lot of risk in talking about depression
and anxiety and how those kinds of
things could be predicted
so we tried to take a more balanced
approach here and since then I've been
putting ethical considerations in all of
my papers it's becoming more and more
common actually so another kind of
approach that's now turning this on its
head or you're trying to remove some
effect mitigate bias in some way is
adversarial multitask learning so I just
talked about multitask learning now
let's talk about the adversarial case
and the idea in the adversarial case is
that you have a few heads and one is
predicting the main task and the other
one is predicting the thing that you
don't want to be affecting your models
predictions so for example something
like whether or not someone should be
promoted based on you know their
performance reviews and things like that
and you don't want that to be affected
by those gender ideally gender is
independent of a promotion decision and
so you can you can create a model for
this that actually puts that
independence criteria in place by saying
I want to minimize my loss on the
promotion while maximizing my loss on
the gender and so how we're doing that
is just predicting gender and then
negating the gradient so removing the
effect of that single it's this is
another adversary approach so you might
have been familiar with like generative
adversarial networks so this is like two
discriminators two different task heads
where one is trying to do the task that
we care about and the other one is
removing the signal that we really don't
want to be coming into play in our
downstream predictions so this is a way
of kind of putting this into practice so
the probability of your output predicted
output given the ground truth and you're
sensitive attribute like gender is equal
across all the different sensitive
attributes or equal across all the
different genders and that's an example
of equality of opportunity and
supervised learning being put into
practice so this is one of the key
fairness definitions it's equivalent to
equal recall across different subgroups
as I mentioned earlier and that's a
model that will actually implement that
or help you achieve that where you're
saying that a classifiers output
decision should be the same
sensitive characteristics given what the
what the correct decision should be okay
so how are we on time there any
questions so far
we good okay cool so I'm gonna go into a
little bit of a case study now and
end-to-end system that Google has been
working on my colleagues have been
working on that is an NLP domain and
deals with some of these bias issues so
you can find out more about this work in
papers at AI a s and 2018 and fat star
tutorial 2019 called measuring and
mitigating unintended bias and text
classification and this came out of
conversation AI which is a which is a
product that's like it's part of this
it's called a bet at Google it's a kind
of spin-off company called jigsaw that
focuses on trying to like combat abuse
online and the conversation AI team is
trying to use deep learning to improve
online conversations and collaborate
with a ton of different different people
to do that so how this works is oh you
can try it out to on perspective API
comm so given some phrase like you're a
dork it puts out a toxicity score
associated to that like point nine one
and the model starts sort of falsely
associating frequently attacked
identities with toxicity so this is a
kind of false positive bias so I'm a
proud tall person gets a model toxicity
score of 0.18 I'm a proud gay person
gets a toxicity model score of 0.69 and
this is because these the term DEA tends
to be used in really toxic situations
and so the model starts to learn that
gay itself is toxic but that's not
actually what we want and we don't want
these kinds of predictions coming out of
the model so the bias is largely caused
here by the data set imbalance again
this is data kind of coming and running
it's had again
and so frequently attacks identities are
really over-represented in toxic
comments there's a lot of toxicity
towards lbgtq identities it's really
horrible to work on this stuff that like
really can really affect you personally
and one of the approaches that the team
took was just to add non-toxic data from
Wikipedia so helping to helping the
model to understand that these kinds of
terms can be used in you know more
positive sorts of contexts one of the
challenges with measuring how well the
system was doing is that there's not a
really nice way to have controlled
toxicity evaluation so in real world
conversation it can be kind of anyone's
guess what the toxicity is of a specific
sentence if you really want to control
for different kind of subgroups or
intersectional subgroups and it can be
even harder to get real good data to
evaluate properly so what the team ended
up doing was developing a synthetic data
approach so this is kind of like a bias
mad libs where you take template
sentences and you use those for
evaluation this is a kind of evaluation
you'd want to use in addition to your
target downstream kind of data set but
this helps you get at the biases
specifically so some template phrase
like I'm a proud blank person and then
filling in different subgroup identities
and you don't want to release a model
unless you see that the scores across
these different kinds of these different
kinds of template sentences with
synthetic the synthetic template
sentences are relatively kind of the
same across yeah all of the different
model runs cool so some assumptions that
they made in this was that the data set
didn't have annotated bias and they
didn't do any causal analysis because
they were just trying to focus in
particular on this toxicity problem and
they used a CNN convolutional yeah you
guys know
with pre-trained glove embeddings this
is probably like your bread and butter
fruit and gloves embeddings I'm sure you
know all about this and we're Tyvek cool
curious implementation of this and and
using these kind of data augmentation
approaches both a Wikipedia kind of
approach as well as actually collecting
positive statements about LGBTQ identity
so there's this project called Project
respected Google where we go out and and
talk to to people who identify as queer
or people who have friends who do and
like talk about this in a positive way
and we add this as data so we can
actually know that this is can be a
positive thing and in order to measure
the model performance here again it's
looking at the differences across
different subgroups and trying to
compare also the subgroup performance to
some sort of general distribution so
here they use a UC where a UC is
essentially the probability that a model
will give a randomly selected positive
example a higher score than a randomly
selected a negative example so here you
can see some toxic comments and non
toxic comments with that example sort of
low a you see here this is a example
with a high AUC so the model is doing a
relatively good job separating these two
kinds of comments and there are
different kinds of biases that they've
defined in this work so low subgroup
performance means that the model
performs worse on subgroup comments than
it does on comments overall and the
metric they've introduced to measure
this is called subgroup a you see
another one is subgroup shift and that's
when the model systematically scores
comments from some subgroup higher so
this is sort of like to the right and
then there's also this background
positive subgroup negatives shifting to
the left yeah yeah this sort of saying
when I said it can go either way to the
right or the left and there's just kind
of different metrics that can define
each of these and the results in this
sort of going through not only just
looking at you know qualitative examples
and general evaluation metrics but also
focusing in on some of the key metrics
defined for this work these sort of AUC
based approaches and they were able to
see significant differences in the
original release which didn't account
for any of these unintended biases and
downstream releases which did which
incorporated this kind of normative data
that said the sort of things that we
thought the model should be learning
cool so the last thing to keep in mind
as you sort of develop and work towards
a creating deeper better models is to
release responsibly so this is a project
I've been working on with a ton of
different people called model cards for
model reporting it's a it's a little bit
of like the next step after data sheets
for datasets where data sheets for
datasets focus on information about the
data model cards for model reporting
focuses on information about the model
so it captures what it does how it works
why it matters and one of the key ideas
here is disaggregated and intersectional
evaluation so it's not enough anymore
to put out human centered technology
that just has some vague overall score
associated to it
you actually need to understand how it
works across different subpopulations
and you have to understand what the data
is telling you that um so here's some
example details that model card would
have who it's developed by what the
intended uses so that it doesn't start
being used in ways that it's not
intended to be used the factors that are
likely to be affected by
disproportionate performance of the
model so different kinds of identity
groups things like that the metrics that
that you're deciding to use in order to
understand the fairness of the model or
the different performance of the model
across different kinds of subgroups and
factors information about the evaluation
data and training data as well as
ethical considerations so what were some
of the things you took into account or
what are some of the risks and benefits
that that are relevant to this model and
additional caveats and recommendations
so for example
in the conversation the eye case they're
working with synthetic data so this is
the sort of limitation of the evaluation
that's important to understand because
it can tell you a lot about the biases
but doesn't tell you a lot about how it
works generally and then the key
component in the quantitative section of
the model card is to have this both
intersectional and disaggregated
evaluation and from here you trivially
get two different kinds of fairness
definitions the closer you get to parity
across subgroups the closer you're
getting to something that is
mathematically fair okay so hopefully by
paying attention to these kinds of
approaches taking into account all these
kinds of things we can move from
majority representation of data in our
models to something more like diverse
representation for more ethical AI okay
that's it
Thanks
[Applause]